Maria is on the line in Temple Texas
Merry Christmas Maria how can we help
Merry Christmas and thank you all for
taking my call the ring for my call
today is my husband and I have recently
been you know having discussions about
finances and you know 39 I'm 31 and you
know we make a good income and we're
just to the point where we're sick and
tired as you know just you know at the
end of the year not having any money so
we've been having that discussion of you
know and I'm excited because you know
you know he's looking at our finances
like that you know I've been a listener
but just trying to get him to you know
be on the same page with me has been
difficult and then we've got the
language barrier as well well bottom
line you know everything he's telling me
is sounds great except for one thing he
did tell me that he wants to take out of
you know we're out of debt we don't have
any debt except for our mortgage and we
have a link we have 20 acres of land
that were on home sits on and we owe
$23,000 on it and what he's proposing we
do is he wants to take out a 401k loan
out of his 401k and I've listened to
Dave and I know that he says that's not
a good idea
but before I you know present to him and
tell them you know much that let's not
do that
my question was why is that not a good
idea what's it what financial
implications does that have like in the
long run well as you start to look at
this Maria and understand there's a
couple of things I want you to do on the
front end the fact that your husband has
now engaged in this process where he was
resistant before I want you to
congratulate him I want you to thank him
that he's interested now and looking at
that because that's a big deal and as
his spouse you were his number one
cheerleader and I think that's such a
big deal for couples to work together
but here's the deal on the 401k loans
the deal is is you've started to put
that money aside so you can live on it
later and have a financial future if you
take that money out there's a couple of
things that happen you stop compound
interest from growing okay and compound
interest is our best friend where we
and when we invest because that's when
our money starts making money so we
don't want to pull that out and stop the
growth but here's the other side when
you have a 401 k loan if you were to
leave that job which means you lose it
or you leave it
that 401 k loan becomes due and payable
within typically 60 to 90 days you have
to pay it back or it's treated like a
withdrawal and I promise you when you
start to have those kind of things with
Uncle Sam it's like tapping them on the
shoulder and it means you're going to
have a tax issue later so it's just bad
all the way around but kind of get your
your your ducks in a row and talk with
him about it because we don't want to
stifle his desire Rachel to attack the
debt but we want him to understand Maria
and so I think the path you're on is a
good path we just want to clarify it
right and and I think as you're
explaining all of that Chris it's like
the more you take on the more
complicated it becomes sometimes when
you complicate finances that's when you
get in a mess yes if you just stick with
common sense and you realize you know
debts not going to help you it's going
to hurt you in the long run debt steals
your future it steals your sleep at
night it steals so much from you and so
the fact that you guys are debt free no
heck no when I go back in debt and
absolutely not and even though it sounds
fancy and good but look at the basics
when you're going back in debt you're
taking on risk and everything you just
explained Chris like I mean that's just
wrist I just see I just see red lights
flashing so to stay away from that and
again - and I want to make the point -
of the relationship and the marriage
coming together because you guys talking
about it is huge so couples out there
you have to be on the same page and men
out there you heard her she usually it's
the woman who's is doing the budget that
we're finding who's taking the lead on
the finances because for women for us
money is security and when things are
not talked about and we don't know
what's happening we feel insecure we
feel nervous but as they if you're
married and you you're you and your
husband get together and he starts
getting on board
I promise husbands your wife will be so
thankful that you come along and help
because you guys have to be unified on
the subject you guys would be so rich so
fast and be able to do so much not only
for yourselves and for your family but
for others
oh we're dead